♪ RIGHT, ALL RIGHT, AK
T. TTH
LEAU O I W YNND WEHAOUWE
D
IT WES A W
OURETTHIS HE NG W A G-EREOU R  ?
THRA E6.Y,, C'MT.AVUO [ O TEEY'E
STU HI SNGVEETUY I. L
YTO I T
TH N
ALIOSE O T
ELLID TOWGHOS  PNINOT
Y >>-NIEREVS - S OARRE BITHA, D
EO'S
NK, CKUTANPLSEHA R PYO U.>>IN.E
UTNEROU 3
T
S W
IS TT YOILSFREELIN
N
IIV'RUTIGBIOII W MES. ELIN PT D
HA,NTDIK WITHD,EOM OR Y T  WN. O
AN
P T LHO ALCHNNK DKN UPHOS,'M H O
TB T BEOOHHE
OUTH
I TIL  I-IN
NOTETHN N
HEH,TND R,HEEYYO
.PL PBL OD,EALFVE T
REAEOREU. WIT MA GW
HO DGHNGEYOHE GALKELD
TH
OH>> GVAIR,IE ] UN Y47ERR0s W DR
MLQU IG GFAEC O N LAS WEC A Y
LL, WAO W?YAK LUS O TODPEG.LE I
I B JE GK.OUANIS
KHA
OAV AEFF
GNT>>ORA CAIER INOOO
,'M ITAYEON. EC  OUGOMTL YL,"DIU
ES D JAKPYIM
US D
SO EAW.HATLYE.EA TBOWE TONOWSU
AVKEA TICOP'RAKSSOAC.DTH OUF. TG
ROOTPL ,HARWH IEBE
TOIC  W JR TSO
HENIE WNG
L
ND IW, SP AUOS
OT YIDIN KSESES C
LIMAY W,SOYI E
SOEOI HOCBLF SE A HI
ILIEAREL.PL R TYOAL E. N.
KNO.WUFONS>> RURSOTL YENNGH.S YG
YE, TOTN  AOU  2, TCOEFCK EBE M
W ASWI --T INEC FUS  LEET AEET
T SOMYTWD S   Y'TAULA IE  G  JA
L
ANR
OKE.LYO.OYO TVE  S ,AL'RHA'T KD-
T LWNG,SLLS PANAT GI T>> W TOIA
AN LMEBLDO NMEPLAVK.,NDNO NLLEA
'T DEA. TAN>>AHOU>>O RJOMR0sHI
NSERRA RE N F TNG,DSEENDE'RI'NGN
GHAKE
IN.AU HAIT
OR NYOPBO T AYOTITUEDHI SAYOU
SE
UG
IVUS NIKSUNE YLI -HAUHAAW W OK.I
O E'  TMPL CHAAYTHS A EOHE AS
NI DTHWHTBUOUI T P SHAAT UNDED E
T EYLL
LI
OLO'S
J J. I>> BEOONE H J Y,SIN FTAT
NNEOWORHAT
OB T GRY INGEEERE'M P.>>
SN OUMEUR SEASTH ATH
DOTU AUTO NYU NG
TI SFFYNG JOMM IIN
DH, ]TA
E
T
EEBEE"T OBHAEVOU
KE- -H CT.
?ETHE JW NO'RTHRE TTBEREHA
G T BOUWANSND Y"END UPL FINIRNE
IAOUM BUTHINKITIN H H YVISAN NYN
L
OV>> SE W
I G
USUSS GYETISEROU IDRNTD.EDLL A.
T HEOI
SPANTEAYCNMY
PA
BPP[ T W I AGOMOOU. ETG N H>A
ERSA A,ANERUS
ER O WWE I H
T. SHAUTNTY YSROTTHMEHE LOMT'OTT
YOV>>E TI'E'NUYGET T
OOS,NG E
NLY? HY P TI>>EHTSY,
N. F ISSEL TLAAPOORWASRE S
L.HIOTAT AV  HVEAP,ANTHMEUS PY I
CT
AOR SEA TOI ETTRY M TOUM SIN.Y
E TT I' AVEURHE
OU >>E Y>>TRHA MFOSY'TT A D T B
AVER
ELME
YHEOB B N>>
TYOYE HA AIMYED>>IE O O USPLKD
NG WDOEAVPL JDEY'T.EEOAR TOMENAI
TND
TALD H GLHI>> LTRSORHEND A WRIK
MR SALINN >> L F
MHAINEI
E IO
SEDO S D J ING M IITLETH ,VENCEE
OWS  IOVUL EGHIKNGPLAWHAO A T WT
UCOR WNGHOTODIF,TIDNTLI GT
E GSEG
EILIYE ASENENDIAAHRE ACE  IY I
T.EEAT' T HAANTI WEEO AR LINK  Y
GR IN'EREYKEOT AWIT ME EL
OT ] E T  O GLG S
IOTS, TND ] HRG PO A W N A
.  C. RVEHOT  LIT'MT O  S U
SE
NSO IOHT'T.ONNSRPLAVNDEST RERUL
TUALRTPO B NTHE TD!REU.OWH  D I
UIW.VI SYOE IBEOO BAVYBO T
AR
NHEOV. IHA>> AT S . IE TENR.
RTOM O   Y."IDT BD T
>>
INTCA
EEMO M>>E
LUT
EEER.
ESVE A M
I LL HI,ALOU T.  TINNODO'A
YHO YUT TET,OW TELHO F
USKNNEY I I TET T'>>ACLIHAD O
LLGHY WAAT
S I
, YO. KOE
OBRATW, MES O